hey welcome back to good works tractors
got a good one for you today talking
about the five worst tractors you can
buy 2022 edition we did a video a year
and a half ago give or take and cover
the five worst compact tractors you can
buy
however we're gonna give you a different
spin on that today different angle now
i'd encourage you check that video out
if you haven't seen it we're going to
give you the specific models in that
video today's video is a little bit
different perspective on that to try to
help you avoid those pitfalls making a
bad decision attractive purchase is a
big decision you don't want to make the
wrong one so stick around we'll point
you straight hey really quick we are
proud to be sponsored by borah wheel
spacers tractors are naturally tippy
side to side so if you've had that
experience you want to make sure it
doesn't happen again i'd encourage you
to check out borah link down below and
we'd love to have you join the family
subscribe it's completely free hit that
button down below you'll get notified of
new videos that come out we have over
450 videos out there already so a lot of
stuff for you to take a look at if you
are in the market for something for your
tractor we sell and ship tractor
attachments all over the country visit
goodworkstractors.com all right well
let's get this party started you know
what i want to start off on a high note
i don't want to be a debbie downer just
talk about the bad stuff so i want to
give some love to the sub compact
tractors in general those are one of my
absolute favorite sub markets the
subcompact submarket
that's out there today they have kind of
revolutionized and just transformed the
whole compact tractor world in general
the 1025r i think is leading the charge
with innovation the ease of connection
of their loader of their bucket of their
mower deck of their backhoe just all
around is just top notch the kubota bx
is right on its heels really coming out
with some good innovations but for me
the 10 25 is second to none all right we
gave you something sweet it's time to
take that medicine here we go now make
sure you stick around because there are
two tractors that are going to be on
this list that i would not take if they
were free and i refuse to sell them
anymore at my dealership before we get
to that i want to share something about
the tractor industry in general you know
something a lot of us don't really know
you see it come up on forums from time
to time but there's really very few
parent manufacturers there's a lot of
tractor brands that are out there but
they all roll up to just a handful of
actual manufacturers that are making the
chassis the transmission and the engines
all right to give you a few examples of
what i'm talking about let's talk about
the manufacturer de dong which is a
korean company they are the parent
manufacturer of the brand their primary
brand i would say which is coyote in
fact they are now manufacturing the
recently reintroduced bobcat line of
compact tractors and they also had their
name on the mccormick lineup as well now
they may not produce every single model
within another brand's lineup but they
are going to have their fingers on it
tym is another interesting one of course
they do have their own brand but they
are also making tractors for branson for
rural king they used to make them for
cabela's bad boy the list goes on
there's a lot of other smaller
manufacturers as well that they white
label for it's just interesting to know
how one company can represent so many
sub brands and then we're going to have
another pretty good sized company lsm
trim which of course is going to make
the ls lineup of tractors but they also
have their fingers on the cnh brands as
well so your case tractors your new
holland tractors mccormick farm trax
some other brands and again this is not
all of their tractors that they're
making but there could be certain series
certain sub compacts or compact models
that they have and this isn't
necessarily a bad thing because it means
that perhaps if you have one of these
other dealers that are near you maybe
you have a new holland but you have an
ls tractor i had this happen a while
back i actually purchased an ls tractor
i think it was a 47 48 horsepower
tractor it came with a new holland
manual and the parts were
one for one the identical the same exact
thing so it could work to your advantage
to have one of these brands that works
with a lot of different
white label partners that they have
because it can make it a lot easier for
you to find parts if needed and there is
one that a lot of john deere haters like
to point to as well which is that yanmar
makes attractors for john deere well i
do know that for a short period of time
in history i think it was the early
2000s that was the case yanmar was
making the tractors for john deere but
that's not the case anymore yes yanmar
does supply the engines and they've
supplied the engines for pretty much
every john deere compact for decades and
decades they're an excellent top-tier
diesel engine manufacturer and you
should be proud to have one in your
tractor but the persistent comment that
yanmar is still making john deere
tractors just simply isn't true and it's
getting kind of old guys okay so first
up on the list we're going to combine
these two groups which are going to be
rental tractors and auction tractors
i've seen my fair share of rental
tractors over the years and i can tell
you one thing's for sure they don't get
worked very easy you have all sorts of
different operators that are on there
running for a weekend running for a day
renting for a couple hours maybe a week
whatever it is they don't care they're
just working it to get their job done
they have varying levels of experience
with the equipment now most quality
rental companies do have good mechanics
on hand they service they inspect they
repair they're on a good program to make
sure it's maintained as needed but still
that doesn't diminish the fact that you
have so many different operators so many
different scenarios that that tractor is
being used in for me that is a situation
i want to avoid now oftentimes you find
those tractors going up for auction and
that kind of ties us into that but
typically if you're seeing tractors
going on auction that means that they've
been sitting on a dealer lot or some
other location for a period of time and
no matter what they do when they lower
that price they're not able to get it
sold and typically at some point that
sales manager is going to say i want to
get it off my books and clear it out and
they're going to take it to auction and
let it sell for whatever it goes for but
if they couldn't get it sold while it
was on their dealer lot there's got to
be a reason for it and typically it is
not going to be the price it's going to
mean that there's something else going
on with it there and for me i don't want
to inherit those problems now i used to
buy tractors on rare occasion from
auctions if i wanted to get a certain
series or a certain model in and i've
all but eliminated that i haven't bought
a tractor from an auction in years
anymore i found that you don't get very
good deals out there i found that many
auctions put a surcharge or a buyer's
fee or some kind of a premium that can
be anywhere from 10 to 20 depending what
it is which is just gonna drive that
price up even higher i think that's
something that a lot of buyers go into
it not realizing as well now it's not
that you can't find a steal of a deal
from time to time at an auction but for
the most part they are so popular
there's so many guys that know what
they're doing you're just not gonna find
those great values okay next up pretty
much everybody in the compact tractor
market wants a tractor with a loader of
the hundreds or maybe it's thousands of
tractors that i've sold over the years i
can think of two of them that guys did
not want the loaders on that we removed
the loaders took them off and sold those
separately every other tractor has had a
loader sold with it sometimes we've
bought tractors and then added the
loaders ourselves to them if we can make
the numbers work but that's very
challenging and i always encourage folks
do not buy a tractor i just had this
conversation with a gentleman the other
day
he found a gem of a deal a beautiful
john deere 790 tractor but it didn't
have a front end loader on it you can't
buy a new one you can get a new
aftermarket but if you're looking in the
used market you're trying to save some
money so if you're saving money on a
used tractor you want to find a nice
used loader to match up with that and
have your savings all around well it's
almost like finding a needle in a
haystack when you're trying to find a
used loader to match your tractor
typically you don't want to have that
shipped in so it has to be within
driving distance of where you're at it
needs to include the right brackets all
the right components to go along with it
and then of course the price has to be
right too and if you're looking at
something a little bit older like that
john deere 790 it's not made anymore
there's no replacement series that have
a compatible loader to put on there that
means that all those folks that have a
john deere 790 without a loader are
constantly keeping eyeballs on the
market looking all over craigslist and
facebook to try to see if one pops up in
their area so it's gonna drive the price
up you're gonna have to jump on it right
away it can be a long and tedious search
so using the 790 as an example all those
folks out there in the market right now
that have that tractor model without a
loader are constantly checking the
market on craigslist and facebook to see
what's out there what's available that's
going to drive the costs up i've heard
of guys searching for months and months
sometimes years and years just to find a
loader to add onto their tractor trust
me you're going to be a lot better off
passing on that 790 without the loader
to find the right machine with a loader
already on it you're going to be a lot
happier now on top of loaders you got to
make sure you have a quick attached
connection between the end of that
loader and your bucket you do not want
to have a pin that bucket it's another
item i'm asked about constantly which is
can you sell me a conversion kit to make
my pin bucket into a quick attach
whether that's john deere or skid steer
quick attach it's a very expensive
proposition to do that after the fact if
you're ordering new try to get that
option built right in don't get one of
the goofy quick attaches that some of
these manufacturers offer stick with the
big ones primarily the skid steer quick
attach and even if you're looking in the
used market as well pay close attention
ask that question if you can't clearly
see it in the pictures
make sure you have a quick attached
bucket that's going to allow you to put
on a set of pellet forks a snow pusher a
grapple a bail spear all sorts of
different attachments very quickly and
easily it's going to open up a lot of
options you won't regret it now i'm as
big a fan of old tractors as the next
guy there's just something about a
classic tractor chris and i grew up with
a ford eight and a nine end up at my
grandpa's farm but you know what those
old timers just had a special skill set
that unfortunately i did not inherit and
so a lot of you guys out there you get
nostalgic i think right you see these
cheaper price points of tractors like
that eight ended at nine and you think
that's what i want to have the downside
is is that they typically require more
maintenance than modern tractors and so
you need to have that skill set but you
also need to have the ability to get
those replacement parts when you need to
which can be harder and harder to find
but as with anything typically if it's
going to be older it's going to have
more downtime which means you're
spending more of your time working on
your tractor instead of working with
your tractor getting your projects done
and i get a lot of folks i want to trade
those tractors in on the newer tractors
that i sell and i don't want to take
those on trading you know we want to
sell
clean lower equipment here we're very
specific on what we want to carry so
this isn't knocking those older tractors
if you're a handy guy and you can figure
it out i'd encourage you to get one but
for a lot of folks these days that are
just now moving out to the country they
weren't blessed with that skill set just
like i'm not so i'd stick to the modern
day tractors now on that note even for
you guys buying the newer tractors
whether that's john deere kubota coyote
mahindra ls bobcat you name it you still
want to have that dealer support that's
nearby these newer tractors have longer
warranties on them long powertrain
warranties many of them are five six
seven years long so if something does go
wrong you want to be able to take it in
quickly to your dealer that's hopefully
not 100 or 200 miles away have them
repair under warranty minimize the cost
to you out of pocket you know if you
don't want to handle your service on
your own as well it's nice to have them
right around the corner at least in the
next town over so you can take it in
there have those oil changes the regular
maintenance done now fortunately in the
day and age that we live in if you can
handle the simple maintenance yourself
which a lot of you guys can with
greasing with oil changes and air
filters and whatnot for most of us these
tractors are typically going to require
one major service interval a year which
can be done on a saturday afternoon and
one of our gwt discount club members
247parts.com
is an online john deere dealer that
carries all sorts of those parts for
your service for accessories for
whatever you need you're going to visit
their website 24 247parts.com you enter
code gwt you're going to get your
savings they'll ship it right to you all
right now i promised you a couple of
specific models and these are going to
carry over from that old video these
still remain true i want to make sure
that you avoid these tractors i know
you're going to hear some folks out
there that don't have an issue but this
is a big chunk of money that you're
spending on a tractor and i think
there's so many other models out there
so many similar models that you can
avoid these ones if you find a good deal
on it it's a good deal for a reason okay
so the first model that you want to
avoid if you can is the kubota b3350
just google that model kubota b3350 and
then put the word problems after it
you're gonna have hours of reading
material they just have issues up and
down the board with their dpf their
regen it's just a constant battle yes
there's some stories of it being covered
under warranty but there's a lot more
stories of it not being covered under
warranty if you want to get that series
but save a little bit of money look for
the kubota b2650 or you can look at the
new generation now the kubota lx series
the lx 2610 and the lx 3310 both of
those are going to perform very well for
you just do yourself a favor and avoid
the 3350. now john deere's not off the
hook here either they do have a problem
child of their own and i was bit by this
one myself several years ago in fact i
had a john deere 2320 and had that model
that specific tractor sold actually i
was still working out of this garage
we're standing in right now at my house
and i had just taken that tractor moved
around to the back of the house to get
it out of the way for a little bit of
time when i went to turn that tractor
back on and move it back up this way
guess what i heard a loud clanking noise
right underneath the floorboard i turned
the tractor off i hopped off and looked
underneath and there was just hydraulic
oil spilling down i had sheared off the
drive shaft where the u-joint is at and
the way that mine broke just happened to
break inside the trans axle so this
turned out to be over a four thousand
dollar repair i had to notify the
customer who had bought the tractor but
not taken delivery yet and in turn they
wanted to cancel that i don't blame them
at all and i sold that tractor for parts
to somebody handy who could fix it on
their own and another john deere model
that had similar problems for a few
years was the john deere 2305 so again
2320 2305 do your homework on those if
they had the u joints replaced it's not
going to be much of an issue the problem
was that there was no instruction in the
manual that told owners to grease those
u-joints which were tucked way up
underneath there there was no easy way
to access it no way to really know about
it and so they would dry out they would
seize up they would fail mine just
happened to fail in the most
expensive way so again i'd encourage you
just plug those models in and type the
word problems after you're going to have
all sorts of reading material you know
if you think the deal is too good to be
true there's probably a reason why it's
priced so low just to get rid of it and
at the very least ask that seller the
questions ask them if these parts were
replaced what the service history was
like what they know about it because
maybe they did something to correct that
problem ahead of time but the last thing
you want to do is get yourself into an
unknown all right guys well i hope you
enjoyed that and it helps you out with
your tractor buying purchase if you want
to learn more about tractors make sure
you hit that subscribe button and check
out our hundreds of other videos we can
show you different tractor models
tractors in action different attachments
as well and speaking of that when it
comes time to make your tractor
attachment purchases we can help you out
visit goodworkstractors.com we sell and
ship tractor attachments all over the
country i want to thank you for taking
time out of your day to stop by and
until next time stay safe we'll see you
soon
[Music]
[Applause]
bye